uh new exclusive images too from the
southern border over the weekend after
the texas department of
public safety seized 16 firearms and
more than
3 500 rounds of ammunition
also 181 pounds of meth from a single
car
officials say that vehicle was heading
south toward the border into mexico
lieutenant christopher oliveira's the
texas department of
public safety is with me now lieutenant
we check in about every other week with
you
what's the status this week well good
morning bill thanks for having me so as
you can see there from the photos as as
mentioned
uh our dps troopers were busy over the
weekend uh we seized those weapons and
of course the
181 pounds of methamphetamine which is a
significant seizure
that our dps troopers made and that's
just one of the largest
weapon seaters that we made we had a
weapon seizure back in april
where our dps troopers seized 20 ar-15
rifles
and over 16 over 6 000 rounds of
ammunition
so significant seizures that were made
over the weekend from our dps troopers
it is almost june lieutenant what are
you
and your men and women noticing now is
it becoming more or less or has it had a
a steady pitch to it coming across the
border
bill one thing that we're seeing it's
it's increasing uh we know right now
increasing migrants coming that's
correct so
what we know and i'm telling you from
what we see on the front lines what our
men and women see on the front lines the
ones that are working the border the
ones that are out there
working those elements day in and day
out this is not decreasing by any means
with the constant surge of migrants
coming across the cartels
criminals on the u.s side are exploiting
that current situation and they're going
to profit off of that
and that's what's happening right now
and it's not decreasing by any means
whatsoever here is your governor greg
abbott from over the weekend on the
drugs coming across the border with
maria
the texas department of public safety
patrols the border every single day
and they've seen an 800 percent increase
in the amount of fentanyl
coming across the border they seized
this year
enough fentanyl to kill every man woman
and child
in the entire state of new york what the
border crisis
is doing that biden has opened up it is
enriching the cartels
who profit off of uh moving fentanyl and
other drugs into the united states and
it's americans on the streets of
major american cities and in small towns
all across the country who pay the price
for those drugs lieutenant
that was correct and the governor's
right on point is what he mentioned 800
increase in fentanyl
um and that's because of this surge
that's taking place this crisis right
now so the criminals and cartels are
exploiting that situation they're gonna
profit off of that
and by allowing this to happen you're
empowering them even more so
the texas department of public safety
under the direction leadership of
governor abbott
has deployed a thousand texas department
of public safety
personnel to the border to help combat
this current situation right now
lieutenant thank you for your time good
luck to your men and women down there
lieutenant oliveros thank you